hello and welcome to this video playing
logo then I am if this is a vague idea
no it's a GM double roguish okay haven't
played them and well that's surprising I
didn't didn't think I never played this
time okay okay just once more at least
I'm quick here in this in this opening
I actually think a five is a good move
okay yes friso libor played against me
yeah I know it opens up ok this is no
this is not a problem 9 p-7 is good
because I get one route traded now yeah
it plays on cup of style as in cup of
moons ago let's see not sure that this
is such a big deal i can also just
returned it's not a problem oh and do i
go back or not and I think I can do this
there should be six even look a success
probably probably am possible ok what's
now maybe just back here normally this
doesn't lead to much this is a side a
file a foul play
in car post game against one's ego then
main difference was that one sticker had
a much worse and peace configuration
then I have him especially the nights
were not worse in this in this classic
game it's something that i had spent by
the way it's the game that i had
featured on my channel it's one of the
all-time best games of anatoly karpov
and one of those monumental squeezes
that he and that he sometimes inflicted
on people okay um bishop to be eight is
the move that I'm curious about yeah i
think i can do it i oniy I don't want to
blunder the house in this position where
I can I mean I can have time yeah I
could improve but I think this should be
a does not a bad moment him don't see
anything bad happening to me here okay I
can take now and queen well I don't have
to
Bishop checks rube cheeks look textbook
chicks I can still do this covering that
Bishop okay three was a pure waiting
move I think I wants to go to a 3m this
is this is sometimes an idea which okay
I think I can clarify this now and go
back there yep wants to activate this
but we'll see I don't don't think it's a
big deal where do you go to be 6 that's
a self-penned so don't believe in that
much hmm to a 5 ok yeah it's difficult
to do something active Queen to be 7 you
will probably player ok seven months and
make a draw if I get in who gate I don't
have anything to fear but i probably
don't get it in
yeah it's difficult to do something
active as i as i stated i can try not to
be six foot
we should see eight yeah it's kind of
it's kind of pointless right I try to
win here I can just can just repeat with
97 and I mean try to win doesn't mean
I'm better I just try to keep the game
going one white idea is them is the
piece seconds you form for two pawns it
is something that is a constant IDM
ready for rugae six now and I mean like
he can take it's an interesting try to
take on c4 here it's got everything
geared towards that idea I don't think
it objectively works but it's blitz
chair so I can you can try ok it doesn't
want to
mysterious yeah this is kind of stuff
ahead on the board a million times check
and have won this end game a lot let's
see what happens here check yeah i'm
somewhat better him with the jeep on
coming up check check no night over to
f4 maybe on i also have night a for now
I think that's also and probably useful
to to play hmm ok so just gaining lots
of space morning Knight f3 this he has
to check on g2 Jackie I'm going for this
and yes some some space issues here this
has some some chick made
there's some kind of way to meet him
here I don't know if this is good jack I
want to try to win check late yeah i was
thinking about it mate for a while and i
got one in that's nice yeah i mean this
is the kind of game that lets me play
this line what simplify you soak up that
pressure on the queenside they don't get
anywhere and in the ending you have some
chances especially if you know their
know the ideas yeah i think that the
best way for might is really how noble
played against me in this in this game
we just played a five he shut down the
Queen side and just piled up on the
Kings side which is maybe something that
black can't stand by the deserve it's an
awfully an awfully boring position I
mean boring is wrong it is also worth
yeah but it's also it's not attractive
to play so I played for him and for
those trades he and I think here I'm
probably I probably have equalized and
now he can try to repeat here but I
wanted to win now and I mean as I said
I'm not better but yeah I wanted to
continue to play as I just know that
position quite well
here create 7s given by the comp might
be even that so bad I don't quite see
the point I can bring the King again
here and play brocade and that's oh it's
okay it's a pretty resilient position
and my idea was just to continue to play
here got destroyed it and now already
this is a bit nicer for black the engine
wants to go at five this is this is
quite nice actually I was thinking more
in terms of improving pieces still but
it makes perfect sense I his pieces are
currently really passive and something
like that there is this idea this idea
so it's really awful ok I am I had this
plan therefore surprised me a bit to
check well here black is somewhat more
comfortable I don't think I should win
but it's a bit it's a bit nice of her
Black Jack Jack the energy for that it
must be really good but I couldn't find
I couldn't find a clean win ok Knight f3
is a clean win which I did Jack see
antique sticks ok he doesn't have King
III as C 3 years hanging against man and
f2 first ok and then take the pawn
looking at four very nice and I we know
the pawns ok Knight f3 was the what's
the point Jack and now King takes wins
when I can probably just promote no King
takes
I probably from OT IM just this is
strong check now okay so it was a
winning ending I just didn't didn't find
the most precise way to do it all night
takes III now was a move ok went by now
I also had to be quick I saw this idea
of 93 and what was going for that and it
it leads to win so she's not I didn't
play it terribly badly yeah this is a
Duke's one it's really a suits one is
also this major you five this name is
made very cute czech make it is actually
forced made right he cannot move the
king 'if I've snipe III made and Yan I'd
be three is the main thread anyway so it
can only give a check check this this
now it's not a force made ok but it's at
least a first win okay thanks for
watching